foreign
[Music]
trust is fragile don't break it once
broken it will never come back to its
original shape
[Music]
learning to trust is one of life's most
difficult tasks
[Music]
a relationship without trust is like a
car without view it can't move forward
[Music]
if you are a real human being you will
never break a promise a heart or trust
trust goes out the same door from which
doubt comes in
money is more powerful than trust most
of the time
you may be deceived if you trust too
much but you will live in torment if you
don't trust enough
[Music]
he who does not trust will not be
trusted
[Music]
trust is built on consistency
you must trust and believe in people or
life becomes impossible
where large sums of money are concerned
it is advisable to trust nobody
[Music]
there's never a reason to trust someone
if there's a reason then it's not trust
have enough courage to trust love one
more time always one more time
trust takes many years to build a few
seconds to break and forever to repair
[Music]
never be afraid to trust an unknown
future to a known God
[Music]
better to trust the man who is
frequently in error than the one who is
never in doubt
trust has to be earned and should come
only after the passage of time
[Music]
whoever is careless with the truth in
small matters cannot be trusted with
important matters
[Music]
people went rightly and fully trusted
will return their trust
it's good to trust others but not to do
so is much better
indifference is expensive hostility is
unaffordable trust is priceless it's all
about relationships
trust begins with faith but not blind
faith
trustful people are the pure in heart as
they are moved by the Zeal of their own
trustworthiness
being trustworthy requires doing the
right thing and doing things right
[Music]
for every good reason there is to lie
there is a better one to tell the truth
[Music]
when trust is high communication is easy
instant and effective
love and Trust are powerful they can
change the fate of a person
do not trust all men but trust men of
worth the former course is silly the
latter a mark of prudence
trust in what you love continue to do it
and it will take you where you need to
go
a lie can travel Halfway Around the
World while the truth is putting on his
shoes
trust your instincts and make judgments
on what your heart tells you the heart
will not betray you
it is more shameful to distrust your
friends than to be deceived by them
trust is the glue of life it's the most
essential ingredient in effective
communication it's the foundational
principle that holds all relationships
trust is the fruit of a relationship in
which you know you are loved
trust is the foundation on which
buildings of all relationships are built
relationships are all about trust when
you have to become a detective it's time
to move on
[Music]
trust and faith bring joy to life and
help relationships grow to their maximum
potential
love means jumping off a cliff and
trusting that a certain person will be
there to catch you at the bottom
there is no medicine in this world to
recover from the Damage Done by the
failure of trust
[Music]
trust is like a vase once it's broken
you can fix it but it will never be the
same again
when the person you trust the most
breaks your trust get over it by
building a bridge but never let them
cross it
[Music]
trust is the highest form of human
motivation it brings out the very best
in people but it takes time and patience
to develop
[Music]
love all trust few
consistency is the true foundation of
trust either keep your promises or do
not make them
[Music]
learn to trust the journey even when you
do not understand it
to trust everybody is as foolish as to
trust nobody
every kind of peaceful cooperation among
men is primarily based on Mutual Trust
[Music]
as soon as you trust yourself you will
know how to live
[Music]
trust yourself create the kind of self
that you will be happy to live with all
your life
it's not the mountain we conquer but
ourselves
[Music]
men trust their ears less than their
eyes
fear leads to more fear trust leads to
more Trust
the inability to open up to Hope is what
blocks trust and block trust is the
reason for blighted dreams
[Music]
trust dies but mistrust blossoms
the only statistics you can trust are
those you falsified yourself
trust is like blood pressure it's silent
vital to good health and if abused can
be deadly
always tell the truth or the truth will
tell on you
trust is built when someone is
vulnerable and not taken advantage of
a man trusts another man when he sees
enough of himself in him
honesty is the first chapter in the book
of wisdom
[Music]
don't trust people who tell you other
people's secrets
[Music]
thank you
it takes two people to make a lie work
the person who tells it and the one who
believes it
[Music]
don't trust the person who has broken
Faith once
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody is to trust them
every human being is trustworthy until
and unless they prove it otherwise
[Music]
it takes 20 years to build a reputation
and five minutes to ruin it
glue that holds all relationships
together including the relationship
between the leader and the lead is trust
and trust is based on integrity
foreign
[Music]